ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
hölle meine lieben freunde in der
letzten episode hat den wir hier das
video beendet weil ich schauen wollte ob
unser portal richtig funktioniert was
wir in der letzten episode richtig
gebaut
ich sollte aufhören zu viel vertrauen in
mein leben zu haben in der letzten
episode waren wir zum ende hin noch mal
kurz in den neckar gegangen um zu gucken
ob mein neues schwert portal richtig
funktioniert danke auch dafür enorm
geisteskranke feedback also fast alle
von euch haben das portal mega gefeiert
und die neue portal insel ist auch
richtig cool geworden finde ich
allerdings seht ihr schon ich laufe ein
bisschen tiefer in die hölle aktuell
rein weil nicht ganz weil ich mir
tatsächlich eine menge knochenbrüche
loch hier aus dem neckar holen muss und
dafür seht ihr auch schon befinde ich
mich hier schon wieder in der festung
das hat einfach den grund weil wir ja in
einer der letzten hüllen folgen über die
festung in seinen knochen bio gekommen
sind wo viele knöllchen knochen blöcke
herum standen und diese
[Musik]
um die geräusche her okay okay
ja ich würde mich auch mal ganz schnell
weg bewegen ich bin hier nämlich nicht
wegen blake ross oder irgendwas anderem
sondern aufgrund des knochen biom sich
benötige diese knochen blöcke ganz egal
das ist doch nicht wahr
mein gott alter ich möchte hiermit
niemanden irgendwie stress anfangen ich
möchte nur in das knochen biom was sich
dort vorne befindet das leuchtet ja
immer so blau und hier vorne seht ihr es
auch schon da und ist auch noch ein
bisschen kratzer könnte ich mich darüber
ich war daraufhin auf jeden fall mehr
als 20 minuten in der halle unterwegs
und habe quarz geformt und auch noch
knochen blogger haben gefahren doch dann
habe ich endlich mein portal
wiedergefunden so meine lieben freunde
ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen wie
glücklich ich bin dass ich jetzt hier
zurück immer wenn ich ankomme ist nacht
ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen wie
glücklich ich bin dass ich wieder hier
bin meine lieben freunde der wille das
schild immer noch hier in unserem
baumhaus kann uns aber egal sein denn
und dass sie die bereits den titel
eingeblendet und darüber habe ich heute
noch gar nicht so richtig gequatscht es
soll heute gar nicht so groß um in den
neckar gehen deswegen habe ich das auch
hauptsächlich gerade wanne time labs
gemacht sondern das wird heute die insel
reparatur 3.0
ich hab mir sonne riesige notiz gemacht
dass dann geh doch ganz weg herunter
zunächst einmal verwandeln wir das
komplette never quatsch was ich gerade
auch im neckar wieder mitgenommen habe
erstmal zu glatten quartz blöcken hier
vorne das hier ist alles schon fertig
gemacht im ofen
das können auf jeden fall für unsere
villa nehme ich nehme mal ganz
speziellen kohleblock und packt den dann
hier oben noch mal eben rein so dass das
hier auch noch wenig geschliffen wird
die quarzwerke kann ich schon wieder
nach ganz vorne packen und jetzt fangen
wir auch direkt damit der insel
reparatur denn ich habe mir wirklich
riesig viele dinge aufgeschrieben die
ich heute machen möchte
insgesamt 20 verschiedene punkte stehen
auf unserer insel und ich bin auf jeden
fall happy wenn wir das alles heute
hinkriegen sollten die schere habe ich
gerade nicht dabei die blätter können
uns aber auch gleich dort wiederholen
beziehungsweise wir werden auch nachher
noch eine reise in die savanne antreten
hier vorne wird alles neu gemacht dass
hier vorne wird zu einem weg verwandelt
hier gibt's dann neuerdings eine treppe
runter haarscharf chillig ich würde
sagen ich finde mal ganz kurz eben zu
der quartz will hier fordert das ist
echt eine großbaustelle guckt euch mal
an wie heftig das schwert da hinten über
allem thront im ozean das ist wirklich
brutal die quote habe ich gerade da
vorne in das fass reingetan vor der
villa da müssen wir uns in einer der
nächsten folgen auch noch mal ein
bisschen darum kümmern
zuletzt die villa weiterhin form gewinnt
das ist ja unser dauerprojekt saison ein
bisschen
ich würde allerdings sagen dass ich mir
erst mal kurz was zu essen holen hier
unten habe ich ja immer noch so ein paar
ofenkartoffeln drin
ich habe nämlich gesagt bevor ich hier
noch ganz ganz viel wie anfang erfahren
da hinten anpflanzt und so es sich erst
mal das essen was ich habe auf wir
denken ja ein bisschen nachhaltig und
was ich euch auch direkt zeigen wollte
was ich mir überlegt hat und das habe
ich mir von der hinten auch schon die
laternen mitgenommen war hier vorne eine
laterne hin zu hängen dich fragt niemand
nach seiner meinung und ich glaube wenn
sie irgendwie dann dunkel müssen wenn
man hierher läuft das ist das ganz geil
aus die knochen blöcke kann ich direkt
zu
sollte auf jeden fall ausreichen ich
finde es halt immer so schön wenn man
mit knochenmehl einfach direkt drauf
macht und hier verbucht hat das alles
und so den baum ihr könnt mir auch erst
mal zum pflanzen bringen da ist ein um
das ist erst groß also der auch aber ich
habe gerade da können wir theoretisch
aber auch mal ganz gut sagt er da dran
hängen dann ist nämlich dieser biete so
ein bisschen aus beleuchtet und der weg
sondern auch nachher ja hier runter
gehen klar logisch hier sollen
allerdings an treppen hinkommen nämlich
stein ziegel treffen dass man ja auch
vernünftig hoch laufen kann
die soll es auch hier auf der seite
geben denn man soll ja von beiden seiten
hier ankommen können denn hier vorne
soll ja einkommen habe ich das jetzt weg
gemacht
es ergibt keinen sinn 100 m
hier soll kein weg hin wieder voll neben
der spur agieren die mitte soll dann auf
jeden fall auch so eichenlaub teile hin
so wie hier so dass das alles ein
bisschen abgetrennt ist und der weg soll
dann von der seite aus dann muss ich das
ja allerdings auch mal ganz kurz weg
machen und durch erde ersetzen
da soll der weg nämlich hier vorne dann
rüber gehen und hier vorne hoch und hier
auch noch da kommt nämlich genau auf der
stufe raus und kann ich hier quasi dann
den weg langlaufen der dann hier um die
ecke geht und dann bringen wir den weg
von hier quasi weiter hier einmal rum
und dann kommen wir hier an sind
wundervoll ich hab mir da wirklich ganz
krasse pläne machen perfekt genau sich
auch so das schwert egal alter wie
brutal sie das aus ich würde allerdings
sagen meine lieben freunde wir begeben
uns erst mal ganz kurz nicht auf eine
rabatt ich habe keinen platz ich muss
noch einen neuen village erholen
ja aber der eine schild ja die ganze
zeit oben ich setze das boot erst mal
hier vorne hin sodass wir wissen dass
wir nachher auf jeden fall noch mal in
dieser vale fahren müssen damit
benötigen auf jeden fall noch mehr von
den blättern weil ich den baum ja auch
ein bisschen angleichen wollte was ich
auch machen wollte und der träger bzw
sie fühlen sich ja seitdem folgen schon
leute getriggert dass ich hier immer so
ein lagerfeuer doch schild das werde ich
jetzt einfach mal so nem bauen hier das
wird nachher auch zum weg dann ist das
ja auch gerade und das sieht ein
bisschen schöner aus mit dem weg er was
mir auch geschrieben wurde war
du hast bambus du kannst du da muss doch
ganz einfach an pflanzen und das habe
ich total vergessen dass wir den bambus
jan einer der letzten folgen
du hältst eine schnauze manchmal ist es
auch besser wenn man weiss ein schnauzer
hält ich habe total vergessen dass wir
noch bambus besitz und warum ist von dem
inder man dass da gibt es jedoch so ich
werde den bambus einfach mal hier vorne
an pflanzen das passt ja auch jetzt tue
ich hab mich darüber ein bisschen
informiert denn man kann den bambus
tatsächlich auf sand auf kies auf erde
auf gras setzen deswegen weil ich den
jetzt einfach mal hoch wachsen lassen
die sache ist nur dass der bambus und
das ist das einzig wichtige der muss gar
nicht am wasser stehen der braucht nur
eine menge licht deswegen können der
bruder
naja wir werden auf jeden ich hab gut
ich hab eine jogginghose an die shirt
aber bewegt er sich jetzt nicht er
schwimmt auf die andere insel nehmen das
ist jetzt nicht wahr ich will dem ganz
großen lektion erteilen weil er in
sachen auf kramt die monate wenn nicht
sogar jahre alt sind und jetzt kommt's
du gehst zurück zu deiner inseln ein
paar sekunden später
[Musik]
denn seine mission
er beobachtet die ganze zeit dass schaaf
der wieder hier hinten langen er hat
jedoch nichts zu tun wer guckt ich
glaube ich erst mal das an was sich hier
verändert hat hier ich habe hier den
akazien baum hochgezogen
es kommen wieder zurück zu mir oder was
[Musik]
ich geschlafen man fühlt sich gar nicht
beobachtet
[Musik]
wir sind in der savanne angekommen meine
lieben freunde das ist wirklich mein
lieblingsbaum kann ich schon so sagen
eigentlich in minecraft es sieht einfach
so unfassbar schön dass wir haben in
münchen am start und konzentrieren uns
allerdings direkt mal hier auf die bäume
denn davon brauchen wir eine menge
stimmen eine menge setzlinge und vor
allem eine menge blätter von daher euch
da auch noch eine ganz kurze time netz
eingeblendet da hinten schon seht dass
die sonne untergeht ich finde wirklich
es gibt nichts schöneres in minecraft
als ein sonnenuntergang in der savanne
habe ich mir auf jeden fall gedacht dass
ich mich so ein bisschen mal hier wieder
einschleichen bei meinen freunden einen
guten alten bekannten aus den wüsten
worten vor einem monat sogar noch eine
kiste da kann ich mir mal ganz kurz
sogar noch meinen sand rausnehmen bitten
wir sie die der restlichen sachen
generell und die kiste dann auch mal
mitnehmen denn die benötigen wir auch
noch für die insel reparatur heute hallo
ich möchte ganz kurz einfach deine wolle
mitnehmen denn wolle ist immer gut und
wollen benötigen wir nachher irgendwann
wenn wir dann mal endlich den leuchtturm
fertig machen ich weiß gar nicht mehr wo
die hier betten hatten ich glaube sogar
nur hier vorne drin aber das war einmal
belegt weil die davon ja spaß hatten
auch mein gott
zu dritt sogar hier oben ist noch 1 6
gegen den steck ich selbstverständlich
auch wenn wir brauchen ganz viele dinge
für die bauminseln für die blumeninsel
dann möchte ich euch ganz kurz doch was
sagen da habe ich nämlich einen
kommentar gelesen wo leute meinen ich
finde sie jetzt schon voll traurig wenn
auf dem tier insel dann das schweigen
das schaf und balu ist dann gibt es gar
keine richtige unterhaltungen mehr und
so weiter und so fort weil das schwein
und das schaf also die stadt tiere mit
dem wir quasi immer den alltag
verbringen auf einer insel die bleiben
alle selbstverständlich auf meiner insel
uns erhalten die werde ich nicht rüber
packen allerdings werde ich mir da
beispielsweise da mal ein paar andere
schafe holen oder noch ein schweinchen
so dass sich die auf die andere insel
packen kann weil wir eine menge bäume
brauchen für den leuchtturm und da macht
das einfach sinn was ich vorhin
allerdings auch noch sagen wollte war
dass ich die blumeninsel doch nicht so
umsetzen heute wie es in einer der
letzten folgen gesagt habe und zwar doch
nicht auf der insel bei der villa
nebenan sondern ich werde die
blumeninsel verbinden mit der tier insel
damit sind hier einfach gut geht damit
die da entspannt ein paar blümchen haben
auch deswegen nehme ich hier gerade die
ganzen setzlinge mit damit ich dort
einiges an bäumen pflanzen kann und das
haben die tiere finde ich auch verdient
nachdem die auf meiner insel immer nur
so recht eingeschränkt waren und vor
allem die kühe die ganze zeit eigentlich
nur im kuhstall geschielt haben und dann
würde ich sagen hier vorne war er unser
büdchen ich bitte euch nochmal ganz
große tablets ein wie ich jetzt fordert
zudem villiger dorf fahren damit
benötigen ja auch noch im neuen village
guck mal
hiervon ist immer noch das schaf und
wartet auf mich um mein gott die delfine
springen ja ronald schild mannschaft
werden wir auf jeden fall aber
irgendwann holen
da läuft über den wild lang gefordert
das kann sich vorstellen was das für ein
chaos projekt ist allerdings möchte ich
erst mal die ganze wieder situation auf
die beine stellen und dass beide village
auf meiner agenda holz direkt mit
aufnehmen oder da brauch ich gar nicht
aussteigen
obwohl muss doch jetzt ist er drin und
jetzt haben sie sich mit ihrem fest das
ist ja schon wieder eine stunde später
der halter schräder
wie heftig krank sieht diese ich bin
stolz darauf
[Musik]
ich bin auf jeden fall sehr froh war
dass alles was wir bisher erreicht haben
allerdings habe ich mir eine neue ich
jetzt gar nicht richtig im boden
wenn die beine gucken vorne raus beim
würde ja auch unten naja ich hab mir auf
jeden fall eine taktik überlegt wie ich
diesen villiger eventuell den richtigen
beruf geben kann und zwar werde ich mich
dafür hier erstmal ganz normal
hinstellen der erwartet da erst mal ganz
kurz und jetzt nehme ich den komposter
baue ihnen ab und setzte den gleichen
direkt vor ihm und dann weiß er dem ich
genau dass das hier sei es wieder zurück
auf der insel ist das schon okay also er
wird dann auf jeden fall direkt checken
dass das hier sein arbeitsplatz ist also
ich steigen aus und er kommt jetzt hier
hoch wenn er oben ist hat sich direkt
vor ihm den kompost ab
ja das habe ich gleich auf die insel man
ich habe direkt brücke gebaut also
kommen wir zu ich kenne sogar noch ein
breiter bauen so kommen los jetzt der
bambus ist schon ein bisschen gewachsen
komme ich da dann nicht na jetzt drei
neue boss ok kuli können tatsächlich
richtig hoch werden also fast so sogar
wie man portal insel schwer da hinten
was er 40 blöcke hoch ist er vorne er
versteckt sich aber der kommt nicht mehr
muss ich ihnen dass sie ganz langsam
hier den den weg über bord doch doch er
kommt auf jeden fall ganz langsam ja der
sich ernährt sich ganz ganz langsam
wir müssen einfach nur warten kommt
kommt
[Musik]
unser kompass sein wo ist der weg
der kompost das wegziehen holzstufen so
anordnen bekommen warum ist er denn
jetzt plötzlich wieder da das kannst du
ja nicht ausdenken was das der finne
geskriptete scheiße ist also ich weiß
nicht ob er da hinten noch auf seiner
insel schild oder ob es vielleicht sogar
schon ins bett gegangen ist weil die
sonne ja schon untergegangen ist dann
müssten wir bis zum nächsten tag
abwarten allerdings steht er hier mit
dem anderen okay die beiden stehen hier
regiert in das bett und er hier komm
runter der gar komm runter ich stelle
hier den kompost 1
das ist nicht wahr das ist nicht wahr
das ist nicht wahr
du gehst nehmen den komposter hier ja
ein wunderschöner neuer morgen erwartet
uns in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
welt männer lieben freunde er macht beim
web gerade fertig und ich würde jetzt
sagen ich bereite mich jetzt erst mal
auf die insel reparatur vor ich bin zwar
in der rue aufnahme schon bei fast jeder
zeit gemacht so ich habe jetzt
tatsächlich sechs minuten hier darauf
vorbereitet alle sachen mitzunehmen die
wir für die heutigen zur reparatur folge
benötigen
von daher fühlen wir direkt haben mit
dem wichtigsten und zwar dass sie unten
das war ja bisher immer nur sondern
kleiner hat ja weil sie nicht was das
hier ist das war einfach auch so ein
bisschen gras und so das finde ich aber
nie so richtig schön und was ich auch
nicht so schön finde ist dass dieser
blog hier einfach eine andere richtung
zeigt dass die anderen
deswegen machen wir als aller erstes mal
den hier in die richtige richtung
nämlich so dann sieht dass hier auf
jeden fall ein bisschen proportionale
aus und wir nehmen uns die eichen
holzbretter und machen hier den boden
erstmal aus eichenholz das sieht finde
ich auch ein bisschen schön aus wenn das
ganze so ist die tür hier um den muss
man einfach verbrennen was mich so oft
abschießen du willst viele unten habe
ich mir überlegt dass ich hier auch
sonnenreichen holzbrett reinen tacke und
dann die tür von der anderen seite mache
damit wenn man sie schließt das ganze
sofort da wünschen ihm verschwinden boah
wie geil das liegt dem schwert ich bin
so froh darüber
die sonne geht schon fassen wir unter
bis dahin möchte ich auf jeden fall dass
sie unten kurz fertig dekoriert haben
denn ich habe mir gedacht dass man hier
so ein bücherregal hinstellen könnte mit
einer laterne dann haben wir nämlich
auch so ein bisschen zumindest nicht
drin ich weiß ich euch die laterne hier
hinsetzen oder sollte ich hier hinsetzen
ich hab' ich hab dir einfach mal hier
hin und dann kann ich mir nämlich auch
einen blumentopf nehmen und hier noch
eine porno mehr reinpacken sich das so
ein bisschen schöner aussehen die ecke
von kleine rüstung ständer macht zwar
nicht so viel sind aber wer oben noch
ein bisschen panische oben flattern und
so dann können wir auf jeden fall hier
hin und dann nehme ich mir jetzt auch
mal meine höfen einen habe ich noch oben
vergessen beziehungsweise da ist gerade
glaube ich sogar noch was drin ja genau
da hab ich noch ein bisschen sand
reingepackt damit wir noch ein bisschen
mehr glas haben für die modernen
das kann ich allerdings auch hier vorne
einfach als hab ich halt nichts zum
verbrennen
na ja wir lassen das jetzt einfach mal
so und dann seht ihr auf jeden fall
schon was hier vorne hingehen soll ich
kann jetzt auch von oben schon mal ganz
kurz das hier nehmen was ich da nicht
ran packen wollte nämlich jemanden
diamant harnisch ich glaube so richtig
wasser für die füße oder hose oder helme
oder so habe ich jetzt gar nicht so
richtig am start
allerdings wird sie auf jeden fall wo
die reise hingehen soll und ich kann mir
auch geben kurz noch mal einen
kohleblock mitnehmen denen ich hier
unten reinpacken kann sind dass das glas
hier vorne am beraten ist fakt und hier
vorne dann mit dem diamant harnisch
einfach rechtzeitig drauf dann seht ihr
schon jetzt hat schon ein bisschen
schöner wenn man hier reinkommen das
sieht jetzt nicht mehr einfach so aus
wie er hier unten ist halt auch so drauf
sondern das ist ein bisschen geiler
vielleicht haben wir das ja auch noch
mal irgendwann zu dingens ersetzen ich
glaube allerdings dass das vielleicht
auch gar nicht klappt genau dass sich
diese blöcke dann sieht man dass nämlich
auch aber das reicht ja auch erstmal die
vier öffentliche vor da es wird schon
wieder nach vorn da gehe ich doch mal
ganz kurz schlafen und kann diesen einen
punkt auf jeden fall schon mal hier
von meiner liste und er packt kennen so
meine lieben freunde ein neuer tag ist
angebrochen und wir nehmen direkt an
unsere erde denn wir müssen das sieht
schon deutlich cooler aus hier unten
naja wir müssen hier unten auf jeden
fall alles mal so ein bisschen
angleichen denn ich hatte ein bisschen
aufgeregt dass die treppe ich auf der
einen seite mal so weitergeht dann auf
der anderen seite nicht und deswegen
habe ich mir gedacht dass wir das jetzt
einfach so machen dass wir das hier so
ein bisschen verlängern und dann sieht
auf jeden fall schon ein bißchen
proportionaler ausfindig oder er wird
auf jeden fall was ich meiner als
nächstes steht auf der to-do-liste hier
vorne auf jeden fall der baum den ein
bisschen schöner bauen müssen
beziehungsweise baidu.com hier schon so
an extra ein stück verrottetes fleisch
mitgenommen wir werden uns auf jeden
fall jetzt in diesem kleinen akazien
baum hier kümmert sich mehr so klein ist
ja gar nicht nahm dafür habe ich mehr
aktien stämme und akazien laut
mitgenommen denn hier oben soll erst mal
noch einen drauf und jetzt habe ich
gerade schon geguckt geht das von allen
seiten drei blöcke hier überall so 123
123 und hier dann allerdings nur zwei da
an den ecken hier das ganze so ein
bisschen abgeschnitten sein sollen habe
ich das jetzt einfach mal so drauf
gesetzt ich kann jetzt hier an der seite
eben
entspannt runter gehen hier die erde
noch komplett eben abtragen
dann könnt ihr euch das von unten noch
einmal ganz kurz anschauen das ist jetzt
nämlich so aussieht sehr sehr sehr sehr
nice aus plus wir können hier jetzt auch
eine laterne dranhängen beziehungsweise
vielleicht sogar ein weiter bunten ich
weiß nicht was das schöner aussieht da
müssen wir mal gucken können dass auch
bei uns in die kommentare schreiben
ich glaube ja ich weiß es noch nicht
genau weiß wo die kommentare die laterne
hier heben sondern da da ich bin beides
eigentlich ganz schön dann habe ich so
ein bisschen indirekte beleuchtung denn
überall auf der insel stehen teilweise
noch so wackeln einfach rum und die
möchte ich auf dauer auf jeden fall weg
kriegen so dass überall hier so
steinbauer rumstehen oder die laternen
hier an bäumen dranhängen oder so zum
beispiel hier vorne könnte man auch noch
einen running oder kann man hier sogar
völlig nehmen das geht nicht
aber hier vorne kann ich dafür einfach
auch ein bisschen schöner aus dann na ja
wir sollten es auf jeden fall gar nicht
davon wieder ablenken lassen sondern
hier vorne erst mal den weg ein bisschen
schöner machen das hier war ja sonst
immer normale grobe erde
da packen wir jetzt auf jeden fall
normale ja dahinter mit uns da nicht
mehr vertun
und was ich auch machen wollte war hier
den eingang ein bisschen verändern
beziehungsweise soll die tür sogar so
bleiben allerdings habe ich mir gedacht
in diesem blog ganz einfach durch
normale erde zu ersetzen das sieht mich
immer ein bisschen besser ausfindig wenn
das sie dann so grün durchgezogen ist
und dann geht der weg nicht ein rein und
dann hört der weg hier auf und dann
geht's wieder das stein an und so das
ist noch ein bisschen besser was sie
auch schon gerade seht dass sich hier
diese teile so ein bisschen ab dass sie
bleibt natürlich selbst wahrscheinlich
das ist ja unser zugang zum bunker da
geh ich mal ganz schnell wieder hoch das
möchte ich auf jeden fall in einer der
nächsten folgen auch noch fertig machen
hier allerdings erstmal den ofen abbauen
und hier die workbench denn hier
es riecht das mache ich einfach kurz so
also ich stehe jetzt nicht mehr ganz
genau hier vorne weil ich ja auch fast
hin gepackt habe allerdings ist dass sie
die kisten kripp ja auf jeden fall haben
wir jetzt ganz ganz ganz ganz viel
stauraum für alle möglichen sachen
werden hier teilweise doppel kisten hier
eine doppel kiste werden dann allerdings
noch fester und hier wieder eine normale
kiste sondern ganz pro kunterbuntes hin
und her
hier kann es sogar auch noch eine kiste
hin das habe ich jetzt allerdings dass x
freigelassen weil man von hier aus
wirklich schön auf das schwert gucken
kann hier vorne guckt man raus sich das
hlug russ schild das ist auf jeden fall
ganz nach vorne in einer der nächsten
folgen müssen wir dann auf jeden fall
auch die kisten sortierung machen
man kann hier oben sogar auch noch die
fichtenholz fallschirm ab machen und
dann dahinter eventuell auch noch kisten
verstecken oder so also hier sollten auf
jeden fall demnächst alle items drin
haben denn was mich immer so ein
bisschen aufgeregt war ich hatte ein
paar items da oben ein paar als es hier
manchmal wenig runter in die höhe
gegangen musste dann nach der formel auf
und das hier liegt der mittelpunkt der
insel dieses gebäude hier
ich hab' ich stelle ist in die sap am
bus gewachsen
alter wie hoch ist der vor allem er hat
ja richtig krawall gemacht und vor allem
der wille vorne denken jetzt wirklich
pharma geworden ich weiß nicht ergreift
sogar oder sind die sachen noch von mir
ich weiß es nicht die beiden arbeiten
hier auf jeden fall und er hat den
komposter noch nicht in betrieb genommen
sonst wäre dann schon so ein bisschen
was drin aber er weiß auf jeden fall
dass er hier hin gehört deswegen müssen
wir den beiden ja ja ich bin dabei
sieben das herz aus eis essen das nicht
an theoretisch den ganzen bambus nehmen
und einfach hier weiter an pflanzen wir
vorne die brücke wollte ich auf jeden
fall auch nochmal wegnehmen das hatten
wir nur gemacht damit der andere will ja
hier entspannt hoch gehen konnte und
hier vorne das ding muss natürlich auch
noch weg das soll natürlich auch nicht
so bleiben dass richtig mit dem netzwerk
hier vorne
allerdings konzentrieren wir uns jetzt
wieder auf ihr hin
nun hatte ich hier noch was vor wenig
sie wollte nur dass sie kurz wegnehmen
weil das ja auch ein bisschen blöd aus
aber die tür da so ein bisschen nach
innen platziert war allerdings
konzentrieren wir uns jetzt erstmal
wieder auf meiner hauptinseln hier vorne
den haben wir auch noch einiges zu tun
zum beispiel wollte ich erst mal noch
einige weitere bäume pflanzen und zwar
finde ich es hier am weg eigentlich ganz
schön wenn hier ein baum steht plus hier
vorne eventuell auch noch dafür habe ich
mir extra schon setzlinge mitgenommen
und da wollte ich hier einfach mal die
blume wegnehmen und hier noch so einen
kleinen eichenbaum hinsetzen eine menge
knochen bin habe ich dann mitgenommen
aus
das sollte auf jeden fall passen das
jetzt aber blöd wer muss ein bisschen
höher macht es vielleicht doch sinn wenn
ich hier einfach noch in erdberg drauf
setzte damit zwangsläufig einen höher
der baum und er ist ein tiefer geworden
es muss doch möglich sein dass ich hier
ein setzling hin
bitte einfach einen vernünftig hohen
baum hier vorne hinter da so genau soll
ich mir das nicht vorgestellt da kann
man jetzt hier nämlich entspannt
runtergehen zum kuhstall der eh bald weg
kommen und dann hier zur seite rüber mit
der laterne dass sie ganz neues aus hier
vorne hassende laterne dann kannst du
hier runter gehen und dafür habe ich
nämlich extra schon ein bisschen schwein
ziege treppen gemacht die wir jetzt hier
so hinsetzen können dann passt das ganze
nämlich auch hier rüber und das gleiche
mache ich auch noch
auf der anderen ist es wieder nach riga
aber jetzt kann ich euch mal ganz kurz
ich habe gleich aus hier vorne sollen
die treppen dann auf jeden fall so
hochgehen bisschen es regnet es ist
einfach im regnen
aber ich find regen so entspannend in
minecraft
[Applaus]
richtig das finde ich immer in kontakt
steht einer ich lege mich jetzt trotzdem
mal ganz kurz schlafen er schild da
einfach und gucken da rüber zu den
anderen villagers alter du könntest auch
einfach rüber gehen das kann doch nicht
so schwer sein
aber gut wir gehen wieder runter ich
weiß ich habe dagegen jetzt auch weg ist
oder ja der regen ist auf jeden fall weg
der bambus dahin ist schon wieder ein
bisschen gewachsen was ich auch überlegt
hatte war eventuell hier so druckplatten
vorzulegen dann müssten wir nicht immer
die türen betätigen
allerdings habe ich ganz schlechte
erfahrungen immer mit zu druckplatten
denn wenn du dann creeper drauftreten
und mir dann irgendwie die hütten in die
luft sprengt dann ist das ja auch nicht
gerade vorteilhaft ich habe mir gerade
ganz kurz noch mal eben die firmen so
ein bisschen ab denn wir benötigen hier
immer noch ein bisschen mehr drohte
damit sich die villa vermehren ich weiß
nicht wie viel wir ja gerade haben hier
ist gar nichts drin
hier ist auch nix drin hier kann ich
allerdings mal ganz kurz die
weizenkörner auf jeden fall reinpacken
ich habe 24 weizen damit sollte auf
jeden fall ein bisschen was möglich sein
deswegen gehen wir mal ganz verzieren
die werkbank und können uns daraus acht
brote machen ich glaube allerdings nur
noch dass das zu wenig ist für die ich
finde so leicht dass man einfach so
komplett drüber gucken kann allerdings
davon ablenken will
ich darf ihnen die ablenken lassen meine
lieben freunde und deswegen
konzentrieren wir uns hier auf in dem
weg der ja hier so runter laufen soll
das soll nämlich so alles ein bisschen
stattfinden und hier packen wir jetzt
einfach schwein ziegel hin
beziehungsweise einstige stufen damit
wir nicht so viele streitige
verschwenden und können jetzt hier alles
so ein bisschen schön machen mit dem
laub dann sieht das nämlich so aus und
ist auch so ein bisschen voneinander
getrennt mehr hab ich jetzt gerade
leider nicht dabei ist dass akazien ist
das richtige oder wir müssen allerdings
ganz kurz mal wieder zurücklaufen und
schaut euch das mal an
schön dass sie alles aussieht diesen weg
hier
das finde ich so hammer wenn man hier so
lange läuft naja was ich auf jeden fall
machen wollte war das ding hier vorne
endlich mal abbauen weil das habe ich
wirklich noch nie verstanden warum der
hier mitten im weg stand ich weiß dass
wir so ein raumteiler oder irgendwie
sowas in die mitte mache ich ja alles
auch so
links
[Musik]
zwischen da rat gemacht ich nehme jetzt
allerdings die stein ziegelmauer mit der
laterne und packt das einfach mal hier
vorne so ein bisschen in die mitte ich
weiß nicht ob ich hier den weg noch
weiter laufen lassen sollte dann hier
quasi so einmal so kommen geht dass man
zur not auch wenn man möchte hier einmal
so lang gehen kann aber ich lasse es
erstmal so das soll ja alles erstmal zu
gras werden beziehungsweise habe ich
sogar ein goldstück mit man kann es
müssen beschleunigen und zwar müssen wir
dann einfach nur den hier vorne dadurch
ersetzen können mit der schaufel rechts
drauf machen und sehen schon wieder dass
wir hier hinter noch die sand blöcke
haben das wird uns glaube ich auch für
meinen plan oben beim haus ein bisschen
in die quere kommen hier vorne das wird
schon noch zu groß werden
beziehungsweise wenn ich jetzt die
glocke schon beim start dann machen wir
alles mal direkt so ein bisschen schön
können auch direkt mit dem knochen mehr
drauf gehen sodass ihr seht wo die reise
hingehen soll das sollen hier alles ein
bisschen verbucht hat aussehen hier
vorne um die ecke auch hier vorne auch
noch und hier auch noch ein bisschen
mehr und dann seht ihr schon wenn man
quasi hier so ankommt hier könnte ich
theoretisch auch noch eine treppe in
sätzen hab ich allerdings gerade nicht
dann sieht das alles hier ganz entspannt
aus hier herunter
ach komm jetzt noch und ich weiß nicht
ob das gut aussieht also ich bereite
mich zwar immer so ein bisschen auf die
folgen vor allerdings will ich auch
nicht alles irgendwie schon in creative
fällt dann vorbereiten weil ich mit euch
das alles mir so ein bisschen angucken
möchte dass ich auf jeden fall deutlich
besser aus also werde ich das hier
darunter auch nochmal mit stein ziegeln
machen zack zack und hier die so sieht
cool aus
das tier kann ich mal gucken wie ich das
hier lösen werde allerdings möchte ich
hier vorne dann auch noch so eine truhe
hinstellen wo wir eine menge mein cards
haben und mit denen können wir dann
einfach drüberfahren hinten zum festland
irgendwann doch jetzt haben wir auf
jeden fall erstmal so einen weg und
können sagen wir laufen hier lang und
laufen eventuell hierüber
beziehungsweise können dann sagen ich
glaube hier rüber und dann bin ich hier
hinten dann beim grab und so weiter und
so fort oder ich hoffe halt hier lang
dann kann ich ja ganz entspannt hier
hoch und hier dann um die seite rom hier
möchte ich allerdings alles generell so
ein bisschen anders denn ich möchte ich
hier komplett drumrum erstmal das jahr
abbauen und alles was sich hier unter
dem haus befindet auch aus stein ziegel
machen denn das wird man sehen und ihr
seht auch gleich warum man das sehen
wird erstmal hier beim weg natürlich
auch alles aus stein ziegeln hier zack
zack sagt dann hier am ball und der weg
soll dann quasi hier langlaufen und hier
vorne fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich
was hier hinkommen soll das habe ich
auch gerade nicht dabei
zunächst einmal möchte ich ganz kurz
noch eben eine werkbank hier hinsetzen
das passt eigentlich ganz gut und ich
glaube wenn wir da schon die ganzen
items haben freuen wir uns später
irgendwann wenn wir eine werkbank stehen
haben hier vorne möchte ich allerdings
die bruchstellen stufen komplett einmal
drum herum ziehen hier so rum
so dass wir dann quasi hier vorne wenn
wir auf den weg gehen einfach nur so
hier hoch und er hat ein erdbohrer im
raum was ist schon cool aus ich bin
schon froh wie sich alles entwickelt ich
bin mittlerweile wirklich auf seinen
stand der dinge dass ich sage ich finde
sie jetzt mittlerweile sogar schon
schöner als vor der situation wo hier
der überfall stattgefunden hat denn
jetzt sieht alles auf jeden fall ein
bisschen gewollte aus auch hier vorne
mit
mit einem blumentopf mit dem bus
springen und so dann können wir das hier
noch so rum ziehen vielleicht so ein
bisschen dann passt das auch hier von
der seite bzw
hier geht es ja sogar komplett darum
hier kommen dann auch noch zwei einzige
rein dafür benötige ich allerdings
steine die ich und aus der höhle nur
bekommen kann
und das passt auch eigentlich gerade
aktuell ganz gut denn da muss ich noch
mal ganz kurz runter und das ausbessern
monster sind hier keine am start
allerdings wollte ich das hier einmal zu
bauen dann hier den network weg und hier
oben war ja auch noch ein loch das
möchten wir auch noch stopfen und hier
vorne auch noch eben alles
beziehungsweise ich werde euch glaube
ich ganz kurze time jetzt eigentlich das
noch eben komplett stoppen hier und noch
mehr steine hole so ich habe auf jeden
fall alles besorgt meine lieben freunde
habe auch genug steine abgebaut hier
vorne ist natürlich selbstverständlich
wieder nach da sind skelette und läutet
remakes der auch träger das kannst du
nicht ausdenken ich habe auf jeden fall
eine menge eine menge menge menge steine
geholt und sogar außerdem auch noch ein
bisschen eisenerz und redstone gefunden
das werde ich gleich auf jeden fall mal
beraten schon jetzt auch hier unten
das soll ich nicht jetzt schild auf
jeden fall niemand mehr die sich alle
gestorbenen hier vorne werde ich jetzt
auf jeden fall mal die bruchsteine
reinpacken hier vorne bruchsteine und
hier eigentlich benötigen wir hier unten
dann sogar noch eine kiste mit der
ganzen kohle weil wenn wir schon da
unten alles beraten
wer ist auf jeden fall gut wenn wir das
mitnehmen deswegen werde ich allerdings
hier erstmals ein bisschen was rein
parken jetzt wichtig da immer noch packe
gesetzt das erste mal so das doofe wenn
man dann quasi in der anderen hand die
fackeln hält allerdings ist es für euch
glaube ich ganz nah weil dauerhaft
einfach nicht am start ist hier ein
kohleblock rein und hier vorne auch noch
einen kohleblock reinigt jetzt mal raus
ich hoffe dass niemand stellt hier ist
keine leute träumen
ich muss auf jeden fall jetzt wirklich
mich mal ran halten ich bin bei über
zwei stunden ich wollte heute eigentlich
eine etwas kürzere episode machen weil
ich
und ja eigentlich auch erst mal ganz
kurz die steine holen mussten mir
spiegel machen muss ich wollte heute
kürzere wieso machen wir die letzte
episode die vorgestern online ging
einfach mal die die längste episode des
kompletten projekt bisher war deswegen
dachte ich mir heute mal ein bisschen
kürzer bisschen insel reparatur ist die
folge schon wieder so lange also ich hab
es nicht geschnitten vielleicht gibt es
ja auch nicht so lang
allerdings bot es sich an mit der länge
der aufnahmedauer bisher bei mir
außerdem noch mal ganz kurze
entschuldigung dafür dass die letzte
episode nicht pünktlich online gegen
beziehungsweise nicht mehr im gleichen
tag und lenken sondern einen tag
verspätung hatte falls wir nicht auf
instagram folgen sollte wissen dass
wahrscheinlich noch nicht allerdings hat
youtube ein video einfach 24 stunden
lang um leute trifft hier
[Musik]
das ist mit diesem thema so kurz davor
zu explodieren hier vorne soll das ganze
auf jeden fall dann so seien mit dem weg
hier einmal darum ihr seht jetzt auch
hier schon die steiniger sieht ein
bisschen entspannter aus und auf der
anderen seite brauchen wir das glaube
ich gar nicht so richtig oder wollen wir
den weg auch einmal drum herum machen
ich weiß es nicht wir können uns ja
eigentlich einmal komplett drumrum
machen wenn wir jetzt hier schon mit
dabei sind zack zack zack das hier geht
ja auch nur bis zur kante deswegen werde
ich dann hier auch schon anfang mit den
bruch steinstufen und hier alles mal so
ein bisschen hier habe ich sogar schon
das alles aus stein ziegeln gemacht
beziehungsweise hier nochmal einer hin
sagt und ihr weg gab
danke schön hier vorne auch noch mal hin
und dann können wir noch mal die
bruchsteine hinsetzen und haben wir
einen kleinen weg um unser haus rum sie
finde ich ganz schön aus ich weiß nicht
ob ich das hier hinter auch aus
bruchstein machen sollen aber ich finde
eigentlich so ein bisschen oder auch
erst einziehen ich weiß nicht ihr könnt
mir gerne in die kommentare schreiben
zieht auf jeden fall echt clean hier
vorne aus und ich habe mir dann auch ein
bisschen mehr platz um uns diese ganzen
schilder mal anzugucken was wir davon
sogar mal streichen könnten ist balu
halsband das haben nämlich schon gemacht
und in die reparatur 3.0 stand so gar
nicht auf bahnstrecke können wir
streichen das haben wir auch schon
fertig alles der wahnsinn
wir kommen voran den rest es ist halt
braucht halt seine zeit bei der letzten
episode hat youtube auf jeden fall
extrem lang gebraucht um das video auf
urheberrechtsverstöße zu überprüfen was
sich halt nicht verstehen weil ich gegen
keine urheberrechts sachen verstoße
allerdings an alle die mir nicht bei
instagram folgen bisschen weise keinen
zugang haben ich kann euch wirklich nur
empfehlen hier bei meinem youtube kanal
auf abonnieren zu klicken ich weiß ich
sag's häufig und management sondern auch
die glocke klicken damit kommt der
benachrichtigung zu weichen neues video
hochladen allerdings sage ich das so
häufig weil das einfach der einfachste
weg ist um für euch herauszufinden wie
was wo was mit neuen videos abgeht dann
videos online gehen und die bekommt
einfach eine benachrichtigung wenn das
ganze passiert und dann ist es halt
immer wenn ich ein neues video hochladen
bitte mir das gar nicht so richtig
klappt das sie wird da auch noch mal
normale normales gras bzw das kann ich
auch ganz kurz direkt dadurch ersetzen
dass ich direkt ein bisschen schöner
aussehen
ich bekomme immer wenden video nicht
pünktlich online geht kommentare unter
der letzten folge von wegen er luca wo
bleibt das video
obwohl ich halt auf inside fashion
längst bescheid gesagt habe hier frage
ich jetzt wahrscheinlich luca was machst
du hier vorne warum machst du das hier
in die richtung den weg noch weiter das
zeige ich euch jetzt gleich denn ich
musste dafür erst mal ganz kurz noch
eine neue schaufel machen die ich nur
hier oben habe denn die kisten
greenpeace ja leider noch nicht fertig
hier ein eisenbahn rausgenommen und hier
zwei stocker ich fühle mich gleich
beobachtet von dem winter vorne
allerdings dass ihr co2 angeordnet und
jetzt eben kurz runter gehen denn ich
möchte auch einen kleinen weg zu unserem
grad machen denn ich finde wir laufen da
so oft kind und das ist ja auch richtig
und so ein weg animiert einer noch mal
ein bisschen häufiger dahin zu geben wir
werden allerdings hier so ein bisschen
platz lassen denn die toten haben ja
auch uns gegenüber platz gemacht in der
welt dann können wir ja noch die erde so
ein bisschen anpassen und das ganze
sieht dann so vielleicht noch mal ein
bisschen schöner aus wenn das hier so
umgeht dass knochen mehr darauf bauen
dass alles ein bisschen verruchte
aussieht dann können wir quasi hier
immer den weg lang gehen hier lang
laufen und uns genau hier hinstellen und
dann
eine schweigeminute einlegen für die
verstorbenen tiere ob wir nun allerdings
zur letzten sache die ich in der
heutigen folge und in der heutigen insel
reparatur 3.0 machen möchte und zwar
wollte ich hier vorne keinen birkenbaum
hinsetzen der hoffentlich ein bisschen
größer wird genau perfekt so habe ich
mir das vorgestellt warum lasst ihr
jetzt direkt kein gras mehr wurde das
weiß ich noch nicht so richtig da hat
man einfach mal ab der sich auf jeden
fall sehr schön aus und hier vorne wo
wir eigentlich den birken baum stehen
hatten möchte ich eine eiche hinsetzen
damit dass hier beim der ist ein
bisschen zu tief ist der ist mir zu tief
damit sind wir nicht zufrieden meine
lieben freunde allerdings werde ich
jetzt einfach nur noch ein zeichen
setzen hinsetzen wir werden einfach mal
abwarten
er soll von alleine wachsen oder der
stelle möchte ich die heutige episode
minecraft mit luca dann auch beenden
wir haben wirklich eine menge geschafft
es sieht sehr schön aus
hier vorne geht das komplett drumrum wir
haben hier den weg drumrum gebaut der
jetzt auch runter geht hier hinten zu
unserer bahnstrecke die demnächst auch
endlich mal in betrieb genommen wird
dann können wir auf der anderen seite
hier zurücklaufen das hier sieht einfach
unfassbar schöne aus mit der laterne und
so ganze hier rumlaufen wir haben hier
neue bäume durch die man sich ein
bisschen durchschlängeln kann wir haben
hier einen weg gebaut rüber zu unserem
grad wir haben hier die kisten kripp
fertig gemacht die wir demnächst auf
jeden fall auch noch gewöhnen müssen wir
haben das hier
da kann ja demnächst mal wieder der
kessel hin allerdings haben wir auch
noch hier vorne alles wenn ich richtig
den weg kann ich auch mal ein bisschen
schöner bauen wir haben das baumhaus
hier unten deutlich schöner hingekriegt
finde ich wir haben da hinten den bambus
stehen und wir haben den villiger der
fahrer sie haben eine menge geschafft
heute meine lieben freunde ich bin
richtig stolz auf uns und ich bin
richtig stolz auf dieses projekt wenn es
euch gefallen hat dass man einen daumen
hoch unter dem video hier da abonniert
main kanal falls doch kein teil der news
seite und klickt auf die glocke neue
videos nicht verpassen wollt wir sehen
uns schon übermorgen einer neuen episode
wieder und heute sollte es eigentlich
ein bisschen kürzer werden jetzt bin ich
trotzdem glaube ich fast einer halben
stunde gelandet
es macht mir spaß von daher alles gut
[Musik]